you guys tonight i'm in portland it's
probably sold out but in case it's not
get tickets check it out esther on
ice.com and this thursday i'm going to
be in san francisco i can't believe it's
finally here and next week i'll be in
new york city you can get tickets to all
those shows at esteronice.com and go to
sleepover by esther.com you will enjoy
today's outfits because everyone's
wearing sleepover but not yet
guys come see me perform stand-up comedy
live i've been having the greatest
experience of my life meeting you guys
vibing with you guys doing comedy with
you guys
come see me in plano texas at the house
of comedy november 11th through 14th at
the punchline comedy club in
philadelphia my hometown thanksgiving
weekend november 6th 26th through 27th
irvine improv
on december 2nd and then i will be in
austin texas at cap city comedy club
november 9th through 11th
bananas comedy club at december 16th and
18th and a bunch more go to
andyletterman.com shows
[Music]
faster when i see the way you look and
then i see that giant sparkler on your
finger what do you mean because you look
like such a little my little baby like a
little kid oh you're my little baby
that's engaged you know wait
congrats you're both engaged is your
engagement real or fake mine's fake
mine's fake
i mean what is engagement it's a fake
made-up thing anyway like are you
actually gonna get married yeah yeah
today i hit up the jeweler that bobby
flaked on
and i was like so what's the deal is he
has he paid you
and he was like i don't think i'm
supposed to say anything you know like
don't
um
but i
strong-armed him into giving me an
answer
so he wants to marry you but he's broke
right now well he i think that he just
doesn't know how to do anything
yeah he he's it's so he's not broke but
the best confused the best example of
bobby is that
when he was younger his
car had like too many tickets or no he
couldn't find his car so he just bought
a new car
right
or let's suppose a flat tire
god forbid you call triple a no you just
buy a new one
you just leave it i'm a handler yeah
i'm a [ __ ] zookeeper
yeah that's what i am that's an animal
trainer and then you add annie and me
into the mix you're a full-blown
zookeeper
[Laughter]
that's wow
shout out by the way nicholas potash so
he makes these amazing like not um
um standard
um jewelry and i was really excited
because he was a fan of the show
and he was like hey let me make your
engagement ring
and
i went on bobby's dms
because bobby's like you do it you set
it up
oh my god he makes you do everything
yeah he made me set up my own um he was
like tell him exactly
yeah not a finger was lifted on his end
does he not have like a buddy who you
could at least predict i am his buddy
yeah
i'm going to have to come out of pocket
for my own ring
oh britney spears style i think she did
that with k yeah with k-fetch wait how
much did k-fed really
make at that time
not a lot if you as a backup dancer like
that that then those
opportunities are not like consistent
how are you guys's feelings on like
having a kept man
are you not the type to like
bring home
no i don't think that's for me
can you define kept
you're just the
the bigger of the you're the money maker
um
see i have a 45 year old man who's like
been living his life
his own way for a while and i'm not a
caretaker
he can take care of me yeah but i want
to like make money and stuff and he
could stay home
and let's take care of the kids
because he's already done his [ __ ] in
his life i'm like you have nothing else
to do but like love me so wait does that
mean that he's already had
has he had kids already no
what has he done that well he was a torn
comic
really so and most comedians are i would
recommend not
dealing with them not at all but i love
he's just like exhausted and tired
and like has nothing left so but love
but
because i'm going to tell you right now
that i've been with bobby for eight
years
and so
i don't like the fact that he
has more money than me because then he
can excuse his laziness and his lack of
intimacy all the other things well i'm
the provider so i don't technically have
to have sex with you or touch you or do
anything yeah i want the opposite i want
to make the money yes so then i can
the other day yeah i was like i'm making
money for this family and my cat so i
don't if i don't text you back
immediately you know what i'm doing wait
i actually use this excuse too i'm not
kidding whenever like my i don't put my
plate away i'm just like some men have
women who don't make any money and i
bring home the bacon and i don't have to
put my plate away
no we have a problem because we're both
messy so i'll be like can you put that
away and he'll be like can you put that
away and i'm like okay let's continue
living our life and we just live in our
own mess because we're creatives
dave is clean
but lazy so like
he wants it to be clean but he won't
actually clean it up for me see that you
can't live that long no i know it's and
you know what he nobody says to me a lot
he goes i hate living with you you're
the worst roommate
he's he says to me all the time you are
the world's worst roommate you're like i
let you have sex with me
i sound like the best
now did you get engaged kind of fast
yeah
why
how
yeah i know eight years i haven't been
able it took me six years
and don't think i didn't beg every day
of those six years
every day my situation was so weird
because i didn't
i didn't really have boyfriends and i
just got engaged
[Laughter]
so like
i kind of met this older man
and then you say older can i ask he's 45
how 30
15 years 15 years that's my parents
exact age difference i love a 15 year
old er you're 13.
you're your mom and your well my mom and
dad were 36 years yeah that's super
that's not a well we don't love a 36
[Laughter]
think that might be pushing it a little
bit i do feel like with same-sex
relationships though people don't look
down on it but then with like you're
right you know you ever notice that with
um sarah paulie yeah like we're like yes
but people are awesome yeah yeah sarah
paulie's like your nickname i thought it
was like your ellie nickname for her
like you know her like no that's just
her filipino yeah something else
oh my god i see an aviator nation jacket
look at this rich girl george looks good
i know
do you want me to throw them on i'll
figure it out
you're the guest so it's up to you
you guys can go in the bathroom this run
the pants went a little small and i just
try them on let's see you know what
it is she's right because i'm wearing
the large those are a large look oh my
god look at her body look at her body
i want to do this thing of like make
your labia clap like can that be a
movement like the like oh you fit in way
too well here
and i'm honestly not loving that it's
gonna be a very very slow clap for me
it's gonna take some time in between the
next one
it'll be a windmill
annie i'm ready
today is the sleepover by esther themed
episode finally you know like a morning
sleepover like we just woke up talking
[ __ ] oh my god we had some ghost stories
someone just got an iv drift
someone's suffering it doesn't feel like
a dream yeah i'm actually getting this
product
i put 13 years of friendship into
getting this [ __ ] sells out real quick
yeah doesn't it
and there's like yeah you could pay
no no these are my gift to you guys is
it so comfy do you love it if you
charged with something if you sent us an
invoice for these
advantage of you being willing to spend
all your money i am always willing to
spend all my money
oh these are great here we go donut
welcome you're my angel dude taking a
dog to vegas is the most inconvenient
did you do it just now yeah i went to
vegas this weekend with donut and she
sucks
vegas yeah i saw gwen stefani and lady
gaga i have a theory that you made a
mistake by not inviting us
no i'm already
i get to meet them no but i have a
theater kalila
[Laughter]
i have a theory that lady gaga
is
at the very least would be a trash
tuesday listener uh-huh because when she
was singing poker face she was singing
poker face papa [ __ ] her face oh she's
saying that i was like she watched last
week's episode oh yeah i'm i notoriously
love being skull [ __ ] hannah oh i love
that for you
thank you i love it for me too
obsessed i like how it's skull it's not
head it's skull
yeah no she puts on she's a swimmer so
she puts on her bathing cap
and her goggles
i hate to be a prude but does that mean
you like blow job i don't get i don't
give blow jobs i get my face
yeah yeah yeah it really it sounds cool
but it's really she's just very lazy
that's exactly what it is tmj it's like
i have to keep my jaw still
i don't want to put any
cervical
movement into it but hey you know it's
already confirmed that meghan markle
listens to the show so
if we have lady gaga on board as well
yeah wait am i ruining a bit or is this
real
it doesn't matter
i'm so cocky about this guys i went to i
went to a starbucks i was in texas and i
was at this like shitty hotel
and i go to walk to a starbucks okay i
walk it's not that far i walk like you
know seven minutes or something it's a
drive-through only
i'm like um okay i don't have a car i'm
like yelling i'm like i don't have a car
wait what state were you in texas where
in texas
um san antonio did you walk through the
drive-through they wouldn't allow me
they were trying and i was trying to get
other people to pay and the girl who was
who was working there i was like she
would like her she doesn't know our show
i can tell but she would like it so i
was like how do i get her like into me
and not to like i believe she would like
it
it was
podcast let foreign through no i wanted
to be like i was i was like doing this
clown thing in my head i was like what
can i offer her that [ __ ] i was like do
you want tickets to a comedy show she's
like ma'am can you stop bothering the
line you should have and i was like i
haven't even started bothering the line
and she's like but we ask that you don't
because she knew i was gonna start like
knocking on windows like take my credit
card get yourself something you should
have just pulled your pants down but
like have you seen this dump truck no
but you know what actually
i did realize hannah the next day is
that
i
had my abs drawn in i was wearing a
sports bra and i had my abs drawn in
from the night before and i looked like
peak psychotic
i was wearing my cowboy hat annie i hate
to tell you but you look peak psychotic
right now
like
well
how is it an inconvenience for a
drive-through to serve a walking person
i've also i you know how many times i've
walked through the burger king
drive-through i mean we knew it wasn't
just for drinks they don't like it but
they'll do it oh yeah so you have done
it yeah you guys were never young child
you look like a loose
like oh we better give this kid her last
name
yeah you do look like an amber alert you
look abducted like you escaped an
abduction when you're young in the
midwest like that's like how you have
fun like that's the that's a thrill
drive through they [ __ ]
let's walk through the drive-through oh
yeah i've gotten fingered at a sonic
drive-through yeah find the roller skate
and buy or like well that's what the
commercial should be in that car yeah
just it's like really like how was your
fingering experience last night i made a
parody of the sonic commercials that
didn't go i made tim dillon retweet and
it didn't work
it's too good you know when you make
something like this is the best thing
i've ever made and it's just the wrong
day and you're like [ __ ]
yeah someone got on the date and you're
like [ __ ] this
oh [ __ ] you meghan markle's talking
about trash tuesday
that's why they left the um queen
hannah wait where are you from
originally i'm from brooklyn new york
whoa you're like the real deal
me and biggie go way back wait that's
crazy i'm from park slope annie would
know yeah so she's a lesbian yeah she's
a lesbian couple that
has two double strollers double
strollers
and we'll run over anything in our way
but i feel like that means you're like
cooler and know all the things that
girls like us like move to the big city
to learn like but i am like an outer
borough chick still so like i'm not like
a cool manhattan girl like you'd be like
oh you're from the city like where
should i go and i'm like i grew up in
like a 10 block radius in brooklyn and
like that's all i did are you jewish or
i'm part jewish because i'm from new
york that's just how it goes
i'm like jewish enough that like
i'm
jews kind of accept me but no jew can
marry me yeah yeah like my mom's not you
did you go on birthright sicilian no i
feel so pissed i didn't go on birthday
because i'm just jewish enough that i
could have gone what's the cutoff age
26. i feel like now they're letting
anyone go though yeah that's true
because they want you to get coordinated
yeah i think they might look at me and
be like
it's a it's a [ __ ] question
according to my 23andme should be all
three of us esther you're out did you go
on your birthright no i didn't well
that's always too scared oh you're so
cute are you scared of what if you're
like travel travel
leaving me taking my shoes off
bam
i'm getting better at it now but
we are
yeah we we talk a lot about like what
vacations are we gonna take as a show
there's one we're actually going we're
actually gonna go to hawaii oh that's
fun yeah we were there's talks of vegas
do you have any recommendations of where
we should go well to me as a new yorker
i feel like hawaii's like europe times
10 like no one ever goes but in l.a it's
like panama city beach for like new
yorkers like everyone yeah
so i'm jealous of that i recommend you i
mean we go to the grossest random places
for stand up yeah horrible but i almost
low-key like i went to buffalo the other
week um i know it smells like cheerios
it's doing well
you know the honey the cheerio factories
are that's why it smells sweet did you
go to the helium yes
i loved buffalo i was eating pizza logs
putting them on my vagina i was just
loving the there was like a water one
waterfall and i was like this is the
most beautiful thing i've ever seen in
my life did you go to that falls no i
know i didn't go to niagara falls either
but i was just there and it was it is
like i love the rust belt i love this
sort of like
factory like vibe i'm telling you random
cities
have like a beautifulness to them you
just have to find like their little
niche it's like a block there's a block
in every town that's slapped yes and
there did you did you go to the gay area
if you i had to walk to go get my merch
i mean i don't know what my life is walk
to a [ __ ] ups store grab a box and
walk back but um i walked through like
every neighborhood
where can i get buffalo wings and
they're like it's just wings and i was
like oh like french fries in france and
they were like what and i was like
so anyway places to visit i'm from i
went to the college of madison wisconsin
which is you did wait bobby loves that
club every person says the club is
incredible it's the best that's his
favorite club what is it called
yeah
okay so your recommendations buffalo we
gotta go on madison okay i'll [ __ ] with
madison dude i used to drive nobody said
greece or
wait i thought we had to stay in america
we don't we don't no we don't we have to
you guys want to go to mexico i want to
take you to scary places and show you
that but i don't want to take her to
like cancun or cabo i want to take her
to like sinaloa michoacan oh yeah like
the deep cuts i've been to watuko
i want to go to chihuahua i know a lot
of boys i used to wait tables with my
chihuahua boys
he was the ugly one but the funniest one
i love how she looks in the camera for
that she was like i know i'm like you're
watching right hey i miss you
esther why did we have to give up cereal
because it's full of sugar and we had to
give up on our dreams we know better now
yeah until
magic spoon ah
you can spoon magic into your mouth
growing quite at a time and i will
for dinner tonight
growing up cereal is one of the best
parts of being a kid wouldn't you agree
yeah but we had to give it up because we
realized it was chock full of sugar and
that's really the junk you shouldn't be
eating not at this age i missed cereal
so much until magic spoon
like i was missing it and now it's back
in my life and i'm so much more happy
and i feel like a little kid yeah i'm
just like so excited that they just
brought back their two most popular
flavors the cookies and cream and maple
waffle and it's permanent they are here
to stay and they're so good i'm so glad
you guys zero grams of sugar 13 to 14
grams of protein and only four net grams
of carbs in each serving it's only 140
calories a serving it's keto friendly
gluten-free grain-free soy-free and
low-carb you can build your own box
available flavors to build your very own
custom bundle or cocoa fruity frosted
peanut butter blueberry cinnamon cookies
and cream and maple waffle you guys can
go to magicspoon.com tuesday to grab a
custom bundle of cereal and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code
tuesday at checkout to save five dollars
off your order and magicspoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
tuesday and use the code tuesday to save
five dollars off thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring our podcast
you guys this holiday season you know
who i'm thanking
my friends at manscaped
god bless them should i tell all my
extended family members that i bought my
man the performance package 4.0 from the
global leaders and below the waste
grooming well you're not going to have
to tell your dad because i already got
him one oh my god annie
your dad and i have a thing i'm sorry
mary okay i love you too as your
favorite comedian you should be allowed
i should be allowed you guys we think
that you should gift your man manscaped
this holiday season so his tree stands
taller if you know what we mean
oh that's good help him join the two
million men worldwide who trust
manscaped with 20 off plus free shipping
with the code trash by going to
manscape.com
you think your holiday spread is good
it's time to give thanks to manscape
performance package 4.0 or as we like to
call it the perfect package for his
perfect package
inside this package you'll find the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer a weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer
crop preserver ball deodorant crop
reviver toner performance boxer briefs
and a travel bag to hold your goodies
think of it as a cornucopia for his
balls and body
here's what i don't mind hair i just
need a little bit of consideration about
the direction of the hair how much hair
the extra grip just needs to be take it
down
just take it down a little show me that
you care show me a fade give me a little
a little pupate i just want to let you
guys know that manscape just launched
their refined body wash and two in one
shampoo plus conditioner and both
feature the manscape signature scent and
will help the man in your life unlock
ultimate confidence this year get 20 off
plus free shipping with a code trash at
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with a code trash at
manscape.com get him the best gift of
all from manscape his balls will thank
you
i did go to puerto rico once and i
trafficked some animals back because
they have all these really great
foundations
and sanctuary
little esther wait what kind of animals
so you see all these adorable animals
but no one like adopts in puerto rico
because i guess they're just animals
everywhere and they're like can you take
this back to like a shelter so i full-on
trafficked like a little kitten and a
little puppy against my fiance's wishes
i was like are you sick you're not
saving the life of a little kitten you
sick [ __ ] um but we so i'm i'm better
than all of you and now do you own do
you did you give the cats to other
people yeah i don't want to talk about
it but i gave the cavs you shared them
you shared the cat i shared my love for
the cat yeah but yeah um are you a cat
person though or did you fall in love
with the street cat i like animals but
which one i'm trying to say is yes i am
a cat person yes and i know we look get
looked down upon sometimes but i think i
have three cats okay thank you but i
also have four dogs i have you kidding
people see the cats
the thing is cats have terrible pr like
they have i
i think that cats are the most brilliant
animals i think that they know how to
take care of them
they're very very they got you left oh
they well no you have to earn them yeah
think about it like i hate to say this
because i hate [ __ ] shaming
dogs are [ __ ] and they will like lick
everyone get everyone pet cats wants
there's boundaries they have
self-respect they can lick their own
butthole they don't need a man
and like
donut we like your body it's a perfect
partner
yeah don't listen yeah and cats also
i just feel like i like earning respect
and maybe that's my own childhood trauma
do you like salt and vinegar potato
chips yeah like a food that kind of
stings yeah you gotta get through some
people say people don't like cats just
can't handle rejection i don't know i
don't mean to throw accusations i agree
with that i agree with that yeah if you
feel like it's a red flag for me where
it's like you just immediately want
something to love you without knowing
you that's a red flag
what if you're like um
i what if you're allergic what if you
identify what did you identify as a dog
yeah and what if you're also a person
who identifies as jacob
wait we've we've talked about this what
are you guys thoughts on a communal
narcissist i think it's the lesser of a
sinister narcissist
basically someone who is
all of the traits of a narcissist but
their charm and character and good will
sort of overrides um their narcissism
it's somebody who
saves animals somebody who is seemingly
very like community oriented so what is
it george
um here are the six traits of a communal
narcissist okay so extreme dedication to
specific charities or causes often
talking about having a mission or a
calling
stirring excess drama or conflict at
charitable or work-related events okay i
got that one
coming across as a martyr uh
i've done a lot for you guys that they
are best at something only seeming to
show concern for societal needs in
public never privately so this is a cult
leader
which i'm very good at yes very
intercourse you know what's weird is
that i just read this thing that like
everyone is a narcissist everyone like
you can't not be one and like some
degree of one and like in fact like if
you say you're not one you definitely
are one because you're like d you want
to be different than everyone and you're
not one well my therapist said this
there's a difference between a
full-blown narcissist and someone with
narcissistic traits because she says to
make it in this industry you have to
have some level of narcissism but
doesn't mean you're a narcissist
because a narcissist has no um they're
almost like sociopathic they have no
like empathy they really have not a lot
of like remorse there
and um if you break up with a narcissist
they'll be certain to make your life a
living hell can i tell you what this is
reminding me of something that i just
learned about like and i know this this
is actually probably not a new concept
to anyone but like
so you know how they're social justice
warriors well
basically like those people who are like
stirring up fights on the internet like
that's just they're letting all their
bad qualities come out through a good
cause
like and it's like so they think that
because they're fighting for some kind
of equality that they can tell you go
[ __ ] yourself you [ __ ] you know so i
once someone like kind of explained that
i don't know if i'm explaining as well
as this other person but like i was like
oh [ __ ]
finally i have i like finally i can see
why those people are in the wrong
whereas i never couldn't could before i
couldn't really articulate it but it's
like they're using anger and all and
intolerance to like push their cause
across so they think that because they
they they hide under a good cause so
that they can be nasty i read this book
when i say i read it i read the first
two pages and i was like oh my god did
you read it
i'm not trying to brag but the art of
public shaming and do you remember that
woman wait are you we landed in africa
who lands in africa because she was like
i'm getting a joke with an aids joke and
then she by the time she landed was so
cancelled fired from everything yeah and
the internet is tweeting at her things
like i hope you get raped and die of
aids like the most horrible things that
are way worse than what she said yes but
because it's under this like
weird but also a lot of these cancellers
are doing it for their own clout of
course so like
you'll see these people
you're not doing it for the better of
the world like is it really helping you
so
overall also a lot of narcissists are
the people who are admired in this world
and i don't want to call people out but
you guys live in l.a
like
you know like even athletes like for
example like i was a tennis player the
best tennis players have such killer
instincts where like they will
squash their mom you know like so you
have so many qualities in the world i
don't know why they would never play
their mom that was just a little too far
but there's and there's so many
qualities that like society loves that
are actually like so [ __ ] sick in the
head yeah
do you know what's crazy okay the book
you're talking about i i have read no
books but literally i've read that it's
called so you've been publicly shamed by
john ronson it it's so british
interesting
and it is all about i've heard it it's
about the like group mentality of
canceling someone and i don't know i
feel like we're finally starting to like
catch on as a society because a while
ago the three of us were being like
attacked by someone because we just said
something that they didn't like and now
i look back and i'm like they were using
us as an excuse to like scream on
instagram it's funny how these
narcissists are able to be like i do
good things for society like a communal
narcissist so none of these shitty
things should matter below even though
they might be like sexually abusing or
like i don't know yeah but all of the
like dude like during the pandemic and
stuff and the black lives matter stuff
when people were posting like where they
donated and stuff like that it's like
i'm always like i never know
i was like my immediate feeling is like
cringe and then i'm like okay they do
have a lot of followers they are like
trying to show that they did something
but it's like i don't know it's always
like a weird thing well that's different
though than someone being like coming
out [ __ ] you you're not like yeah it's
also funny because
it's not at a level playing field like i
was talking this comic and he was like
i've stabbed someone
and no one's canceling me but like my
friend made a joke
i was stopped by a comedian and i
thought with a pen
[Music]
no but like they're like i've done
horrible he's like i used to rob [ __ ]
he's like but my friend's getting
cancelled because he made an off-color
joke about something wow so you're in
those moments and it's weird but
everyone's friends with him but
everyone's like oh that guy smells bad
right now and i'm like this guy tried to
murder somebody yeah
in more of the stories we've got to get
this one comic off
he's stabbing people but group mentality
is so fun to it's like if if everyone
starts like throwing rocks at someone
you throw a rock and it's like well
everyone else is it's so easy to do and
that's what the internet's kind of
enabling and you feel like you're in
like a club or a crew or whatever you'd
be mad you have
a cause a mission
well i got really angry i marched i wore
my [ __ ] hat so embarrassing
[ __ ] out was definitely what is a [ __ ]
hat
after it's the most humiliating thing
that i could even express to it's so bad
that i'm i i'm telling you this is like
the most important it's the women's
march um look at the [ __ ] hat
oh what's so bad about that no
yeah
you said that like i'm like
no
doesn't look like that
i have some level of roast beef i have
some level of pink it's like a it's it's
a mix now what are we talking about oh
you want to see my [ __ ] sure
do you really want to see it yeah of
course i love when delilah's like listen
you can't just say tell me what color it
is tell me the real color
there's some hair because i haven't
waxed yet i'm sure there's basically
there's gonna be
don't look annie it's not she's going to
spread it danny this isn't for you
i'm excited do it wait is donut okay
donut are you comfortable donut is so
unmoved by it it's a vegetarian
look at donut what color is it it's
looking away
it's peach yeah why is it peach oh this
stupid [ __ ]
oh shocker kalila has a perfect [ __ ]
that she's complaining about to try to
fit in it's not pink it's actually a
beautiful color it smells like peach too
[Laughter]
it's very cute thank you i feel like
it's very
similar to mine but that i don't know
really i can't picture mine right now
i never forget a badge
i remember where esther and i showed
each other our vaginas for the first
time was that the alcove oh in the
bathroom i remember i love that place
good bread yeah it's a good bad chunks
that's a great place yeah is that very
easy yeah it's in los feliz it's right
here yeah it's not that far it's really
cute you guys want to go take a trip i
was like excited you found bread in l.a
we have it i swear
um what was it oh did you guys drive in
this in the rain did you like it
yes and it's completely fine and normal
did you like it i i had no opinions i
had no opinion of you you're getting
defensive for no reason because i'm not
one of the people that's going to make a
big show are you sure because on a
bright sunny day you drove down stairs
she drove down some stairs two weeks ago
i was just gonna say i had a lot of fun
i was like driving i was a little high
but um no i was driving and i was like
this is like fun like you know i i
wasn't speeding obviously because it's
[ __ ] raining out but it was just like
it was nice you never get to drive and
rain here anymore annie i walked outside
and there was a full camera crew like
there had been a murder
and people were getting interviewed and
i was like what's going on and they
overheard it and he's like yeah you know
you never know what's gonna happen in la
and we gotta just pull through with the
rain and i was like what the [ __ ] is a
hundred percent
imagine new york city a full article or
like full news day being dedicated to a
droplet no there was an editor of a
paper that got woken up like his wife
had to pick up a phone like hello
the community is about waiting
it's raining shot out of bed
and put the coffee on
[Laughter]
how do you feel about the rain i loved
it it was so i was very excited about it
well it's not just rain right it's a
bomb cyclone oh no this is a
this is a drizzle
well they're calling it a bomb cycle
where's the bomb and where is this like
i feel bad that i enjoyed it from a
[ __ ] typhoon belt
you know
where it's like i come from a place
where most of my birthdays were were
spent with
two weeks of no
no light no electricity because of
[ __ ] and then full-blown karaoke
they're like we have to harness all the
power
in the philippines for this one birthday
party
no but it's like it's so yes i
understand that whole thing where it's
like i don't understand why californians
just cannot function
you know on a drizzly day wait can i ask
how long are you here for the week can
we invite her to your birthday you want
to come to our karaoke extravaganza i
would love to but r kelly used to be my
go-to and now i don't know what to do at
karaoke ignorantly you can order a
lemonade [ __ ] and enjoy it let me tell
you hannah this is korea tell me we are
not going to judge you if you want to
sing ignition that's so funny she had to
retire
from karaoke i'm done like you're like
it was that and thriller [ __ ]
oh my god because when i dropped remix
ignition everyone would respect me like
in a new way like i would advise and
you're good or are you torturing
everyone it's a combination of both to
really nail it if someone's too good
everyone hates you and you gotta get the
vibe yeah the theater major [ __ ] where
it's like i could have made it it's like
you should see i do that but i don't
have the talent that's my energy that i
bring i mean i'll never forget esther we
were we did a show at whitney's outside
whitney's house and natasha bettingfield
was there and i bring this up a lot
because
esther did a dance to unwritten that was
you would have thought rent was written
to esther um
she the the excitement on her face
on written got wrote that night it was
wait natasha bettingfield doesn't get
enough
like respect she's coming back because
the tick tick-tock she i know because
her songs are so my dad likes her the
best she's such a sweet woman too when
he's like gifted us with some people
natasha betting feels one thing i know
we should have her on the show would she
do our show 100 natasha yeah
oh my god it really was i did ask her to
sing on written and i remember thinking
that night i was like everyone in this
crowd owes me because i got her
right
we're all thinking
i want to put one million dollar wager
down that she closes every show she's
ever done with unwritten
no she
no you think she just paused her as your
business manager you cannot put one
million dollars down as my business
manager i want my business manager to
[ __ ] want to make money
you got to get we got to take big risks
for this wait i have a question dude
what is this called this one this is the
sad malibu barbie
which is you're selling it well i love
her
i live in malibu it's a malibu bound and
i also have you matching george
he's also a sad malibu barbie um wait
you're kind of like barbie and ken oh
with the blonde on blind
oh my god well do you remember amy
schumer was supposed to be barbie barbie
um what happened i have no clue i'm i'm
assuming it was a money such who knows
the true hollywood story i need to bring
that show back i really want a female
comic to be the bachelorette that like i
want them to just shake on every guy
and like like be like is that feminism
brad and then like just like i don't
know just [ __ ] guys would be so bad
though they'd be trying to be funny it
would be so horrible
oh i saw that i've always wanted to go
on a bachelor like as a contestant but
while i'm engaged today
and then it comes out it's episode five
like it's the first lesbian bachelorette
it's a psychology like i talk about you
if you're on a beautiful island and
everyone's talking about the same thing
like i would i'd [ __ ] a barnacle yeah i
was a producer in my ear being like oh
my god america's gonna love you like
he's obsessed with you all the girls are
jealous i'm like give me that barnacle
and shove it up my vagina i you know
what barnacles are feminine looking to
me i'm just gonna say it
i don't want to be weird i'm like is she
eating it out how is this working it's
more like a whole like it's more whole
how would you yeah fun fact about
barnacles
she actually had pet barnacles as a
child
that's just creepy but let's hear it
esther did you get your olive in june
package klyla i was waiting for it as
soon as i found out we were working with
olive in june all i did was email bryce
every day where are we getting all of in
june stuff it is one of my favorite
brands so basically olive in june is a
mani system
that gets mailed to your front door and
it's so cool they give you everything
everything you possibly need for salon
perfect nails at home guys are doing
their nails now too we had we had a lot
of guys on the set of doll face that
painted their nails and i think it's so
hot yeah bobby does i'm so into men with
painted nails i don't even know why it's
so hot olive and jun nail polishes last
seven plus days and they do not chip and
with olive and june's mani system you
can achieve beautiful salon perfect
nails at an affordable price oliven
june's mani system is the ultimate
secret behind salon perfect nails at
home all in one no guessing no messy
nails and no salon price tag
the reason i like olive and june is not
because of like the price point of
manicures is one thing that now since
the pandemic when i learned to do
everything at home
sitting at a nail salon for that long is
so boring it's horrible so bored it's
actually horrible i'm glad i'm going to
switch to olive in june so it's pretty
brainless really it's like
like honestly i thought about this when
i received the box i was like this is a
wonderful thing to gift
anybody it's a really good holiday gift
also if they so they send you it comes
with the it's called the poppy which is
amazing i know it's so amazing it's a
patented pat tinted brush handle that
makes it so easy to paint with both of
your hands you become ambidextrous what
other product is doing it's a literal
game changer and how your nails can look
done professionally at home olive and
june is super affordable and they're
nail polish honestly you guys does not
chip
what a what a joy and a blessing
it's a classy brand like this is one of
the nicest brands we've ever had sponsor
us but it's also affordable which is
really nice and you guys know getting
beautiful salon perfect nails at home is
now a dream come true with olive and
june your new nail life is here visit
oliveinjune.com
tuesday and use code tuesday for twenty
percent off your first manny system this
is an exclusive offer you can only get
here that's o l i v e a n d j u n eleven
june dot com slash tuesday code tuesday
for twenty percent off your first manny
system oliven june.com tuesday code
tuesday you guys this would be a great
gift to get for people if you're just
looking to support the show anyone will
love this gift olive in june oh hello
welcome to the podcast that is sponsored
by our favorite brand ever
liquid death i honestly thought esther
would be dead before she got the sponsor
she wanted so bad
you don't understand i have these all
over my nightstand i have these all over
my car all over my house it makes
drinking water feel funny fun
and exciting and dangerous
that's so funny
you guys may start noticing that there
are strange tall boys of beer in the
bottled water section of your local
stores well it's not beer it's actually
mountain spring water from the alps and
it's called
liquid death why is it called liquid
death i don't know just kidding death to
plastic i do like as someone that
doesn't drink it is fun to hold a can
again
when i'm out it does feel good doesn't
it taste better like i love it i love it
and also the sparkling water is so
pop it's so sparkly like it's the
strongest sparkling water i've ever
tried i've been drinking so much of it
lately and it's guilt-free because
plastic isn't actually recyclable
anymore and we know that and most
plastic you throw in a recycling
recycling bin actually just ends up
getting sent to a landfill because it's
not profitable to recycle aluminum on
the other hand is infinitely recyclable
and actually profitable for recycling
facilities keep that in your pretty
little heads you guys can get free
shipping on all water and merch at
liquid death dot com slash trash that's
liquiddeth.com trash or grab some at
whole foods or 7-eleven i didn't know we
got free shipping you guys literally on
my way home today i'm going to order
some at liquiddeath.com
while i'm driving
this is a very unnecessary thing to know
but barnacles cost the shipping company
companies the most money if we could
create a paint that could prevent
barnacles from sticking onto ships we'd
be millionaires because that is one of
the hardest things to scrape off any
surface so don't knock a barnacle hannah
they're kind of awesome they're
very clean i also want to make a new
eyelash invention because i can't handle
the
magnetic barnacle eyelashes
probably the same like it's going to be
the same answer for both there's gonna
be something that's like what's your
eyelash problem it's the gluing of the
eyelashes is so infuriating i i have the
extensions now but that's only gonna
last for so long i'm gonna have to go
back to the glue if we're trying to be
millionaires we're not we're not looking
in the right places i'm telling you
barnacles
barnacles and guano that's the richest
people do the most boring [ __ ] like
pipes plastic there's so many pipes we
need to invest in pipes look at all the
pipes [ __ ] it that bad [ __ ] guano yeah
i have an important question because
you're actually on a reality show oh
yeah what was like your own summer house
yeah can you what was like the premise
like how did it were you nervous it was
winter house
like was it real what like what was that
so the premise was we're a bunch of kids
who work hard in the city during the
week and then on the weekends we need to
go to the hamptons and drink and just
like let loose because we worked so hard
during the week um and that was it there
was no competition but that's what [ __ ]
you up there's no competition there's no
voting out you're just like anything
could happen so it's like the real world
[ __ ] you it's real so there's [ __ ]
there's fighting did you hook up with
people i did i got eight now on tv you
did not blow him after he was very
feminist oh my god what if yeah take my
goddess thank you
yeah
um it was
it was a one of those experiences in my
life that i'm like why not let's do it
and my first two seasons went really
well and then my third season went
really bad what happened
i like stood up to a bunch of guys and
then when it aired i kind of just came
off as like she's crazy and these men
are very logical with their points and
uh well usually they are we are on our
period yeah i was on my period for four
weeks straight which is crazy i'm glad
esther gave you that that color then
and but it was a great experience to
like put myself out there i tried
they want to put you into characters
there's like the hot one yeah the smart
one the you know the boring one and i
tried to be like women could be like
depressed but hot but funny but sporty
and they were like no it's so annoying
that collides you're crazy i know i'm
like we're just the sidekicks
is hot sporty and smart heavy on the
depressed though yeah dude
my last my last season of filming it
wasn't how it was normally we were stuck
in the house for six weeks because of
covid and i was depressed so i stayed in
bed the whole time and then they were
like hannah doesn't hang out with other
people and um but i was depressed and i
didn't want to hang out because then i'd
fight whenever you're probably the most
relatable character on there if you're
just in bed everyone else was just like
yeah i got yelled at because i
i said i want i was gonna take out the
trash
i didn't sign any contracts i wasn't
getting paid i'm like i'll take out the
trash you didn't get paid well no no i
did for the show but not to take out the
trash and there was like 10 people it's
so funny to think that you only do
chores if you're getting paid
no but i'm saying like i got it
out like some guy was like you [ __ ]
lazy piece of [ __ ] you said you were on
the show yeah and he was like he was a
producer that would be fun
the producer just watched and i'm like
could you guys help i'm like no and he's
like raise your hand if anyone else
picked up the trash and all these guys
read their hand the trash was [ __ ]
heavy it was like three flights down the
stairs like rose bottles crazy and but i
knew it would stir some drama i just
didn't know it was gonna be like my
downfall it's also just so funny
it's just funny when you when you offer
to do something before you've like
done it a couple times it was a
volunteer game and you accidentally like
picked something harder than you thought
and like like if you ever have to clean
up like after we this is like so
annoying sorry but after i do ayahuasca
we're all like we've we've had this
weekend of ayahuasca and we have to like
clean up the place we're literally
exactly the first time i picked
uh
um the vacuuming and you just don't
realize how much vacuuming there is so
like with the trash or like this is
heavier than i [ __ ] thought yeah i
got to do it
we had to people didn't know like it was
this mountain with like all these steps
outside and the trash was at the very
bottom where like all the producers were
and i was like i'm not bringing this
down at like midnight and also it was a
very like lax thing i didn't think
they'd make it a storyline but they were
probably in the other like interviews
with the guys being like so this is the
problem if enough people in the
confessionals talk [ __ ] about you it
becomes it's so easy to like they were
like how does you know not not hanging
out with the rest of the group and it
cuts to me like going to the bathroom so
like they could just do whatever they
think they were masturbating the whole
time i actually i was masturbating a lot
i was going
but there's that's what depression is
you're just massive i mean we know that
i watched the whole season of love
island yes which is like three days i
think four i watched them all it was
great but um basically reality tv was
fun until
you're not everyone's favorite wait you
got in trouble on reality tv for sitting
in your room and watching reality tv
it was kind of meta that's very meta yes
and it wasn't on their network
it wasn't that's what they and they let
me say love island that's why they
turned on yep
are you done with the show so i
am not going back
is that because you're engaged i got
engaged and like
it's funny i guess i'm the kind of
personality where like i don't just like
smoothly fit in like i'm either like
love you and like i'm all about you and
loyalty or like if i feel like shit's
fake it's like i can't fake it with
people yeah and that's kind of what
happened in my last season where i was
like ah the vibes are not right
so
and were you already engaged that season
i had gotten engaged right after
but it's it's funny because the previous
season i was like trying to [ __ ] this
hot model and everyone's like we love
hannah and then i met this guy who came
on the show and we like were [ __ ] all
these rooms and they were like hannah's
disgusting and he ended up being the
love of my life so it just doesn't
matter
on the show no i met him before the show
and then was really lonely in five weeks
and i'm like can you please come and
they're like we'll just make this the
storyline and but i thought it was gonna
be like this romantic like beautiful
like thing but instead everyone's like
he didn't hang out enough with us and
i'm like he's 45 and sober but um but
the thing is i learned in my life like
you're gonna have a lot of battles and
some battles
it's okay not to win
but
i wasn't that great on reality tv
no you that's a win though seasons of a
show two out of three i was good but i
either come off like super authentic and
everyone loves me or they're like she's
a [ __ ] and i'm like but i like you all
of us it's like
annie like we would have had the same
thing where people would love you for
two seasons and then you go a little too
far in people like she's kind of a [ __ ]
but i would rather that than be like the
one everyone got along with that's so
boring and i mean i wasn't even fighting
with them it was like people like i
fought with a bunch of guys who were
like accusing me of [ __ ] and i was like
don't talk to me like that and
everyone's like hannah's an emotional
crazy you gave them tv what about the
girls were they nice or like did you get
along with them the girls were
they were i actually did get along with
the girls but the guys teamed up against
you well i do think guys hate female
comics like duh
yes that's what i'm saying that's
literally yellow i mean he's like you're
not [ __ ] funny your podcast sucks and
i'm just sitting there like this is so i
mean it was called cut out but i would
sit there and i'm like dude what's the
actual problem with me because it's not
the garbage
and then i was like maybe i should
surround myself with people who want to
be like creative and fun and talk [ __ ]
and
like that's where i'm at now but it kind
of it was a a tough part of my
entertainment career where like i got a
lot of hate online for a bit just
because it's reality tv and that's what
people love yeah but i've i'm sorry i'm
a comedian i want everyone to love me
and think i'm hilarious i feel like
you're just like you're too weird and
different for that group of people
because that's the nicest thing anyone
ever said to me it's my mented as a
compliment so that's good even though i
was calling you bad things yes but uh
esther's old podcast her first podcast
was weird adults yeah
oh yeah
i loved it but i didn't ultimately fit
in and it ultimately was my demise it
was good in the beginning because it was
great because i was like fun and
different until i became popular and
then people were like oh we can tear
this girl apart because i'm not actually
good with social like i went to a bunch
of different high schools i don't really
know the mean girl games yeah i'm kind
of like we'll just be like what and or
i'll cry yeah
no it is weird
i'm good at like the funny sarcastic
banter but if someone's actually coming
for me
i get scared yeah let's take a banana
break
[Music]
i have a question for you esther
are my holy socks on brand with
sleepover by us yes yes
oh my god you should have someone like
holes in the crotch
thank you
hannah when when emotions um run high or
when feelings are felt on this show even
though we take a potassium break or we
just take one or george waves a banana
in the air
he blows it you guys can't say it's
off-camera
it's deep throat time
and then he's like it's your turn i just
had a big breakfast so
how else did i've ever heard this was
such an esther
everyone do something she's going to sit
back and watch and not do participate
i'm going to watch you all blow bananas
and jerk off under donut
this is your weird fetish you're like do
you guys want to put a banana
i think it's cool you run that i like um
i
i stay in reality tv so i i mean i
[ __ ] love reality tv but i like what
you're doing like what happened to what
you're telling me i didn't watch the
show no offense not because of you you'd
be the only reason i would watch it if
i'm being completely like i will do is
it weird if i go back and watch it no
not at all i the i because then i'll
come back on and you know i'll have a
lot to do
i feel bad i don't know because
i'm gonna love it it's a great watch i'm
i started season three wait that you're
not in
i wasn't in the first two seasons oh
three three to five
oh that's why so you came in like the
cool yeah
okay and then they're like
[ __ ] you are there still original cast
members yeah it was the og cast members
that were like we're done with you oh
okay yeah
so why are they for five summers can't
find a lover
they're looking every summer and they're
mad at you because you found a guy this
is the problem having a healthy
relationship on reality tv is very hard
cause first of all when we'd be filming
they'd be like okay go hit on some bros
at the bar so i'd make eye contact with
a guy
and i'm like i can do this but there's a
camera guy and like four guys holding
lights behind me and i'm like hey guys
would just run down or they'd talk to me
and then afterward they'd be like hey
can you sign this and they're like no
i'm a finance bro like i don't [ __ ] with
this stuff and then let's say you meet a
nice guy and then you're like hey in
three weeks i'm doing this reality show
where you'd have to be a part of it or
like people would not be happy that i
can't hide parts of my life right so and
then the kind of guys that do want to do
reality tv with you are almost as
problematic as male comedians
imagine absolutely makes sense yeah and
then i met a comic
a couple
two weeks before the reality show named
dez
and we like got coffee we hit it off and
i'm like hey i'm doing a reality show in
a bit and he's like figure out your
stuff
i ended up calling him like every night
just crying
being like there's there i just fought
with 13 people and there's only seven
people on the [ __ ] cast and he's like
that's wifey material
but i was like the worst with this guy
like i was maybe like the drama
subconsciously but i was just like a
mess then we'd like jerk off and then
we'd like talk about life like it was
tremendous it was like five hour phone
calls i was also sleep deprived during
it which didn't help my
calmness during the fights oh you guys
had phone sex we would have phone sex
late at night i'd be on the phone from
when filming ended till like 4 00 a.m
i would like go in the laundry room are
you facetiming or no we do facetime i'd
go in the bathroom facetime because
there's cameras everywhere that's what's
so fun that's why i pay for the live
feeds of big brother because i'm trying
to watch people like masturbate and [ __ ]
and you can always tell when they prop
the pillow up like so there's like a
it's almost like a little tent for them
the live feed of big brother like that
is actually better than the show i just
want to hear
the long unedited boring conversations
like and it's fun to let go they're
going to put that in like i'm almost
like yeah
yes
reality the filming is actually like
pretty realistic i mean obviously
there's moments where you have to like
push a storyline but it's the edit where
they sh
contextually put things to make whatever
they want to make sense and sometimes it
is pretty truthful and sometimes you're
like oh you didn't have any other
options so that was like
the craziest thing you're going for
but dez ended up coming on the show even
though his agent was like don't you dare
but he didn't tell him and he did he
want to or did you have to talk him into
it
it was kind of like we were in this very
initial like we had three hot dates and
then i left yeah so it was this like
mysterious like i just want to see you
and he's like oh you know and i wasn't
allowed to see him because of kovid
because if i like met him
and got covered and got everyone sick
like i'm fired so he was like come meet
me and i'm like i literally can't this
is my job on the line
so he finally came and we just like
hooked up laughed had fun he left
and then i kind of moved in with him
like two three weeks after the show it
was a very interesting
dynamic kind of moved in
it was one of those things where he's
like it's just like weird when you leave
and you're like why would i leave yeah
yeah like but it would just come back
here anyway society makes it so romantic
where guys like here's the key yeah do
you want to move in with me and he was
like do you want to get your stuff and
just like and i'm like
i can't tell if you're comfortable with
this you're just trying to make me okay
like i it was a very awkward but i think
that's how most moving in happens
anyways at least for me and bobby i
think on our third month together
because i had a place where we were on
the beach
i lived an hour away i lived in london
what was your place was it i had a
two-bedroom apartment
beautiful yeah we love them um and i
loved it i loved living there but then
bobby was like don't go home live with
me in the squaller
you know this amount of shoes would you
like to organize and clean oh my god i
dedicated a whole month
my mom and i to just redoing his entire
apartment because i was like if i'm
going to live with you
that's what dez did with your emotions
he's like i'm going to rearrange her
emotions
so it does
i got a dumpster
and i was like honey we need to throw
some [ __ ] away and i'm not the neatest
[ __ ] but i was like we i put a dumpster
in front of his house and i think it was
like this like metaphorical like get
that old [ __ ] out yeah because and i'm
not it's like kind of hot thank you so
just like wake something up a little
scary though when you're cleaning out
everybody like someone like bobby's
place
my mom's things are alive in there
my poor mom is like bit by something no
but it's like he's she she's my mom is
like unearthing pictures of him with
like
women and none of this nudity that's the
thing with older men they've had a life
before you right and then so my mom you
know we were just so cool about it we
were just like let's put this in this
box she's like let's frame this one yeah
he looks cute in it and he had so many
contraptions like vibrating things that
for the tip of his dick because he's
into that like brookstone massagers what
and my mom just kept pulling off
i know what to get him for christmas
guys guys are into um vibrators as much
as women you know how annoying it is
though like i went with my one boyfriend
who like we we went to the sex shop and
he was like looking i'm like can we work
on me coming more you guys
like you come so much it's like we have
to double like we have to add more yeah
there's just like a brisk wind like we
need the moon in the aquarius so wait is
that a common did you guys know that
guys want vibrators on their dick did
you but you and you do you know what is
your vibrating
don't go there don't go there with your
brain i got a new toy it's one of the
the like the suction area yeah but i
haven't i haven't tried it yet because i
want to try it with todd what is it the
the the one on amazon for 36 bucks no it
was expensive i went to the end it was
very expensive i went to the sex store
and i asked the lesbian working i go
what are you using
i want to know what you use [ __ ] oh i
love that you're going to go to a
restaurant and you want to know what
they actually eat in the background oh
you guys the pleasure chest okay so
the pleasure chest is in uh on what is
it on santa monica and west hall it's
like an iconic sex shop in west hall and
so they had a tj miller used to run a
show with this guy eli
in the sex shop
my only friend who who visited me in the
hospital when i was there he was trying
to [ __ ] you
for a booklet because he worked next
door no that was when i went
and i had shingles and i think a
ruptured cyst in my opinion i'm too far
so elderly
you were admitted for it like you were
in the hospital yeah because i went and
i didn't know that i had shingles i went
because i was having terrible stomach
pains and they're like we think you had
an ovarian cyst rupture we're not sure
and then the stress from that maybe gave
you the shame and then at the end of the
night the doctor i was like by the way
what's this rash on your back
the doctor dr bronstein uh so such uh
such like hero energy he was like oh you
have shingles and i was like thank you
was it hot
no but you know when you can tell you
get adopt an emergency room doctor who
like really like gets off at what they
do
like i have a damsel in distress complex
so like we just like vibe yeah i miss
you dr bronson
it was a wonderful day in 2016. you do
have a
i sometimes save i like to save you some
time yeah wait so what happened with
your [ __ ] sucker okay i haven't used it
yet i haven't used it it's just sitting
there because i had to go out of town i
got it and i had to go to town i was
like i'm not going to take it and use it
on the road why not without him because
i want to like christen it with him i
want to use it first with him but
i'm so glad i didn't because josh potter
and i had adjoining rooms
and i was like he would i mean he
definitely heard me like blasting ass in
the morning
i was like it's kind of fun that me and
my friend have this
walkway but it also is so weird like at
one point we were hanging out and i was
like he was standing in the doorway and
i was like falling asleep i was like i
had like um
kit kat you know falling on my mouth
like take the cats and run please let me
sleep i feel like joining rooms with
your friend is like a little too much
pressure for me like i wouldn't know
should i keep the door open but is that
going to pressure them to open their
door oh my god we know your door is open
with a [ __ ] yeah
so i feel like conjoined rooms it was
like your dream come true it is with
like some people like you guys is it
conjoined or joined
conjoined twins i know that
so it might be adjoined but is it joined
a world why don't we just say connected
yeah connecting yourself that's the vibe
can i i have a question when you go to a
green room and you have like two random
male comics there i closed the green
room from now on wait what does that
mean you put it in your ryder closed
green room no one's allowed in my green
room
and they talk show you who gives a [ __ ]
i'm obsessed with you because i've i
have this new thing where i'm headlining
and some rooms it's literally a bathroom
with like a tiny green room yeah
you're talking about buffalo by the way
yeah buffalo you [ __ ] have a
close green room now because of you they
come in they sit down they man spread
you go hello
okay it's a full frat room you're like
this is how bad things happen wait who
are these guys coming in no so they're
your like opener and your future and
they're always like great nice guys but
you walk in as a woman you have to bring
your own future now
you just drop the cash it's better pay
for their flight give them extra money
to make it like worth their time get
someone that's good you know cut that
side out for when i bring john
i said get someone that's good got that
part
i have a full nervous like
poop cycle before i go on and it's
totally normal for me i just know and
also sometimes i just want to go and sit
on my phone in the bathroom but i was
like i want to go to the bathroom they
all got all like weird
and i just want to be able to have
explosive diarrhea before my set in
pieces it's very normal
that's not too much stuff and i think
i like i love the buffalo guys but i
think they just don't i mean i just was
like okay and you you have to then kind
of be a [ __ ] to people and be like i
need you to leave but you don't really
want to have to have that energy before
you're about to go on stage with these
people and stuff too so closed green
room no offense
i like to meditate before i go on you
can't be in here sometimes i had an
opener it's always someone that has
asked me to open for me that i've
ignored that has then gone through the
club and somehow gotten
the gig which
they'll be the host instead and then
i'll literally have them put a do not
disturb sign on the thing and the guy
i'm telling to not disturb will just
walk in and go oh [ __ ] oh they put a
sign i would go yeah get the [ __ ] out
wait so do you now you bring josh and
then is it just you guys josh i bring
lizzy sometimes i bring my friend mike
racine but if you bring one person is it
just a two-person show sometimes it's
two-person it really depends on
on what like and sometimes i like to
have another person there it was really
fun with lizzy we had brant tobler it
was in um
[Music]
in colorado and brandt's like local so
he's like a dude doing like local more
local jokes like and then um and then
lizzie's [ __ ] crazy
uh lizzie cooperman is has like a piano
and she's going nuts and then it was me
and then he would come up and bring him
up it was just like a good breakup and
imagine if green rooms were made by
women for women there would be a full
like makeups like vanity like vanity yes
there would be tampons everywhere we
should do that you know that like huge
like male comics ask for crazy [ __ ] like
they ask for like crazy things like so
it's like i mean just like to get them
like a certain type of like specific
alcohol like just things that are hard
to get i think tj miller is like like
you just wanted a pinata in the room i
want to go in exactly like you want to
meditate you're like give me my crystals
i want no literally a candle yes i want
um i want a cord i want spa music
and i want
everywhere i want like a little massage
person just in case i want no i want
bean bags filled with a tampon
i want no but there are well i always
ask for because my open opening i do
stuff with like a lot of energy drinks
so i have to ask for like
so many five hour energies and they're
like they never and i'm like you have to
you guys have to go get them i need them
sometimes there's not even a place god
forbid you want to curl your hair a
little like you can't even find a plug
it is white
would be amazing i have to say i've been
like what in this business for like 10
years i've never thought of one thing i
would want on a writer ever
they always ask and i'm like nothing i
have no idea liquid death or something
it's got like the thing you like should
we talk about um
our um search for a third oh my god
on friday night esther and i went down a
rabbit hole because we were like
we should find we should have threesomes
with our partner
and so we then asked carlos
to wait why you go from threesome to
carlos because carlos
oh we can't believe we're broadcasting
this we can take it out if it's too much
we're not broadcasting
live on nbc um because carlos is the
only person who's connoisseur sees
escorts
and he's definitely not the only person
that's george
um and we were just talking about like
you know opening up the bedroom and
i we agreed that
if you were going to bring someone else
in i think a sex worker is a better
because it's a transition transactional
and you don't have to coach them they
know what they're doing they're they
know what they're there for they're
being compensated
you're just hypothetical
this for me is hypothetical
but then dave is watching this now and
i'm in trouble and we're going to have a
10 minute talk right now i can't imagine
saying to todd let's go get a hooker
what would he say he would say no yeah
dave wouldn't he would be like no
really yeah what about you hannah
des isn't like that into strip clubs
also he's old like you know how many
tits this guy's seen like he doesn't
even care anymore but
maybe like we're also like kind of new
in our relationship so maybe like when
he's sick of my [ __ ] in like a year
we'll see yeah i know down the line you
know you've been together for a long
time a long time yeah same almost a
decade so it seems interesting the idea
of a sex worker would be like maybe
she'll teach you something new
yeah but then the the women that carlos
she's a tutor of sort of showed us
well the women the links of the women
that carlos sent us
they would squash esther these women
were like tall and beautiful and
bodacious and big esther you'd get lost
yeah
it would be an unfair let's be real dave
wouldn't be there
so esther would have full rain dave
would be in the corner possibly
trying to get in would be like
swatting him away
donut would be there
is it interesting to think like because
you want to be into it too yeah to be
like well what
kind of girl would i be into but then
you also want to make sure he's also
into it right but then you also don't
want to get jealous that he's into it
you know what todd might not say he does
watch lesbians he does yeah i don't know
we had that in common
it's my ex-boyfriend and my current
boyfriend yes wait have you brought this
up yet to bobby
no i don't think he would be opposed
though why i think we're just at a point
in our relationship where it's like
anything goes what do you think he would
do you think he would do it he would be
into it or i'd force him into it yeah
yeah she's like
like you don't have a choice right oh my
god you rape him
i think more i think it's probably more
for me than it would be for him because
i just need sort of a shake up a little
bit yeah and maybe do you think you
would be a little jealous watching him i
would love to see him [ __ ] someone i do
like getting jealous i do like the
feeling of getting jealous but when i
feel safe yeah exactly i like feeling
cocked i i am a little there's a little
bit of like i like when someone likes my
man i like yeah with the same same thing
i do but then like him getting pleasure
off of them like that next level like i
love when girls want to [ __ ] my mans
yeah
but you don't want to see it for him i
have a friend i have a friend who who
she in her head she thought she was so
down for this threesome she brought the
girl in it was a friend of hers and the
friend thing is
she that's rough midway through her man
[ __ ] girl she kicked she put her
heel in on his pelvis and kicked him off
of her oh i love that and she was like
enough
and then they probably started [ __ ]
so good after yes yeah really she was
really really nice
he liked it you know he liked it she was
fighting for him i want that feeling
yeah i want that would you rather have a
threesome or
sit and watch
i would probably my first move is to
watch and then jump in if you want to i
just don't want to i just want to feel
like a creep
if i'm like sitting and watching i'm a
lawyer
i would i just want to say this i'll put
this on record i'll say this on record
forever in the room uh all three of you
i would watch any of you guys have sex
with someone if you ever if that
invitation you know what i like too
you're very like hide
you're hideable like
you could pull this off like there's
many like closets like i have a chest
where we put like shoes and like
blankets and stuff like i could see you
popping out of that i was saying i could
fit you into this i could see you into
so many spaces like i if you do get the
escort like i would love nothing more
than to just be there literally there
could be a plastic glass i would walk in
and walk out probably but i would want
to like be a part of like see the thing
i'd want to see what happens i'd want to
you know i'd want to watch you push the
girl off of bobby and then go for him
now esther you um have always and you're
friends with a lot of porn stars but
you've always had a fascination with
porn stars correct yeah now when you
meet a porn star do you think it's like
weird that you've seen them come like do
you feel like you should have seen all
of your girlfriends come
no
like once you see someone come you kind
of like know their i i don't understand
it's like watching someone sneeze it's
just oh really i just feel like it's
like you're seeing someone in an
uninhibited
who is laughter
without yeah that's true that's right
i've never made anyone laugh
or come
i think the only person i would feel
uncomfortable watching [ __ ] is probably
like my sister yeah um but everybody
else is familiar but then you would know
what moves were like your dna yeah like
you'd be like i do that
yes
i feel like i'd be more jealous if des
was like yeah i met this girl and like
she's so interesting yeah like like i
was just thinking that like todd's never
like come home and been like oh my god
this
says someone's hot i'm like yeah she is
hot but if so if he knows someone was
funny that we already knew or something
but it's like don't meet a new funny
girl like wait she's just comic and you
thought they're funny on stage yes but
if you're like vibing with them like in
person like they're creative he says she
has great energy i'll kill myself i do
like though i do like because todd used
to work at the comedy store so i like to
be like
um
like you don't really like that many
he's like yeah i don't think that many
people are funny like yeah but like you
always thought
i was like i'm always like tell me about
the crush you had on i'll tell you what
the most insecure i am is bobby around
artsy cool women yeah if not hot women
like
artsy
she didn't say fartsy
but i know what you're saying yes um in
fact i think i would probably die if i
saw bobby make out with or just kiss
someone like gently versus like
full-blown [ __ ] someone for me it's
mayan's big insecurity is
so sad but people who read books
like if dave got into a conversation
with a girl about books i'd be like i'm
done like what if they read book what if
they read book like
actually you read book
dez loves history because he's been
around since the dinosaur age and i
don't i love like learning about i'm
like what happened like with the world
wars like
before like what happened and he'll like
tell me but like what if he spoke to a
girl who was like and then do you
remember when this happened like that
was yeah but he wouldn't like that if he
loves you then he wouldn't like that you
know wait we have this thing called
professor dave
which is when dave acts like a professor
and he teaches me about something
it's really fun you guys should try it
it's like hot like to respect a guy's
mind like i've never tried it till
recently that's cool
yeah
i haven't i do need my partner to know
more than me i can't be the smartest i
do like learning from my partners and
stuff but i've had boyfriends where it's
like
the amount of dumb you think i i'm not
dumb man
i can't read and stuff but i'm smart
like you can't pull this one bobby's
like too many life lessons i'm like
you're seven years older than me shut
the [ __ ] up bobby's an interesting one
because he's like he is a genius he's
life dumb but he's also yeah he's like
incapable of doing he's like yeah he's
he's incapable he's book smarts does
bobby secretly know things i i hate when
my dumb friends aren't on but she is
such a [ __ ] genius yeah how would you
describe what kind of stuff he's he's
honestly like he's a savant he's
his brain just doesn't operate in like a
traditional classroom way but he is
brilliant in everything else like he is
always like his brain is just on fire
but that's what's cool about him like
you're not gonna meet another guy who's
no he is like him one of a kind he is
his own prototype it has not been remade
what did we learn today guys annie is on
to a [ __ ] sucker
oh barnacles are not as bad which just
kind of looks like a [ __ ] sucker
barnacles yes barnacles or [ __ ] suckers
that's all we learned today we may want
to get into the business of barnacles
yeah correct or guano batshit we're on
the look out for sex workers sex workers
if you well we shouldn't solicit where
did you look though but did you guys is
there like a sex craigslist yeah they're
us they're they're carlos nose and
esther kept she was like that's too
expensive and these it was not even
expensive
carlos said that oh it wasn't that was
carlos she's like esther kept trying to
underpay these women no that was 100
parliamentarians i want to go for the
you tip them you tip them right i don't
know how i don't know that's a good
question let's go to the bunny ranch
let's go to the bunny ranch that's what
i want i would love to go to the bunny
ranch i've watched every episode i'm
done same thing don't go you'll come
with me
please he's dead now yeah but
why don't we just go to the bunny ranch
as an episode yeah we'll go to the bunny
ranch hannah can come wait but are we
gonna actually
um participate we're gonna see what
happens because when i went i met this
sure
bunny bling69 i don't remember what her
real name was
um i met her we took her around i went
with my friend i was going to buy him a
breakfast blow job but then it was 1500
and i was like sorry
but she gave us a tour i tipped her 20
bucks we chatted she introduced me i
bought a vibrator i bought the vibrator
that's like looks like a toothbrush it's
pink
um
and
that was it but you could hang by the
bar and just take in the vibes can i at
least can i tell you guys what you what
you're wearing yes yeah so annie's in
the sad malibu barbie
and i have no tits i'm sad lila is in
the enchantment under the sea dance the
colors are from the back to the future
poster wait say that what's the name
again enchantment under the sea dance
that is made for me yeah
that's the blood from all the fish you
kill
that's true
hannah and off camera pete are wearing
the i spilled my grandma's wine and it's
hand-dyed with a potassium spray gun
that's why it like looks like like an
old lady you used to wear it
and this is though it looks like you
sneezed in your your grandmother's ashes
and this one is not out yet but it
probably will be when this comes up this
is the overlook hotel so it's the colors
from the carpet of the hotel in the
shining you are so detail-oriented it's
this is all i have
guys i hung out with that store a lot
over the pandemic this is
it was so funny is like i really was
like surprised when you passed it off i
was like i bet you this [ __ ] will just
hand dye these for the rest of her life
but i've never seen you you were so
into it i it was very impressive
everything i made myself was bad it was
so ugly
she would give me a cute one i'm like
who made this she's like dave i don't
know
i like the kylie lip kits of tie-dye
like it sells out immediately and i'm
obsessed but yeah these are all made in
america and in la and i'm getting
nervous so i'm going to stop talking why
are you getting nervous let's get to the
root of it
go to hannahburn.com for stand-up
tickets i'm going to be in flo ryda i'm
going to be in
north carolina i'm gonna be in boston
and in new york actually are we bringing
an opener
i mean we have to talk [ __ ] because i
need to get new rules and new writers
and i need to cut some people out of my
life um and then listen to my podcast
burning in hell mental health comedy pod
i'd of course love you all on and giggly
squad also so cool that you were on
caller daddy i loved your episode oh my
god thank you you were like the first
guest
i was one of the first post the breakup
it was a lot of pressure that was crazy
it was really good thank you i
appreciate that i love collabing with
hilarious women and i'm it was actually
such an honor to be on the spot because
i literally yelled at my peoples and i
was like if i go to l.a i just want to
be on trash talk shut up
but that's what trisha paytas calls it
as well yes you're not alone guesses
with the three girls i wanted um trash
tuesday and it's an honor and a
privilege thank you
good our clips are but on the microphone
yeah i don't care about anyone's podcast
actually but i see your clips and the
aesthetic and you always hit with like a
punch line that makes me giggle and
yeah you guys are doing a really good
job and you should be proud of
yourselves thank you so much and
everyone should go check out your shows
and your podcast burning in hell which
is so good do you have two
and my podcast giggly squad which is
from my friend from the reality show i
have seen clips of that it's so funny to
just you literally are just laughing oh
my god yeah we just giggled it's just
it's so fun no joke it's so good thank
you and then you follow me at being
burns on tick tock and instagram or
wherever your tech talks are so [ __ ]
funny i pre this is like a masturbation
ring and i'm really into it with annie's
[ __ ] sucker i know and yes speaking of
[ __ ] suckers um esther did you want to
do your days
you guys thank you so much for listening
we'll see you next week bye
like and subscribe
[Music]
you